his need to Rally the world Community
clear with his presence for the first
time Ukrainian president veloda mayor
zielinski addressing the United Nations
General Assembly in person and in
English
in an attempt to send a clear picture of
the horrors of War zielinski detailing
the plight of tens of thousands of
Ukrainian children he says Russian
forces have kidnapped and sent to Russia
we are trying to get children back home
but time time goes by what will happen
with them what will happen to them
those children in Russia are taught to
hate Ukraine and all ties with their
families are broken and this is clearly
a genocide
U.S President Joe Biden clearly wanted
to send the same message Russia alone
Bears responsibility for this war
Russia alone has the power to end this
war immediately
and as Russia alone that stands in the
way of peace because the Russia's price
for peace
is Ukraine's capitulation
Ukraine's territory
and Ukraine's children
but on the sidelines there is talk that
it may be time for peace that Vladimir
Putin could be persuaded to make a deal
chatter zielinski pointedly rejected
he says Putin is untrustworthy pointing
out the fate of a one-time Putin Ally
who seemed to cross him and died in a
plane explosion and I am aware of the
attempts to make some shady dealings
behind the scenes evil cannot be trusted
Ukraine's expect to take Center Stage
again here on Wednesday as the U.N
security Council meets to talk about the
war and we expect that President
zielinski and Russian foreign minister
Sergey lavrov will be in the same room
for the first time since the war started
Paddy cohaine Al Jazeera at the UN
headquarters